It's been more than 30 years since the height of the HIV-AIDS epidemic began in the U.S. The survivors of that epidemic are now middle-aged and are still learning how to cope. In the meantime, more effective treatments have changed how the disease is perceived by the public. Perry Halketus, a psychologist and public health expert, talks in this episode about how psychological science is even more critical in understanding how to prevent HIV and also how to help those who live with all kinds of chronic diseases. I'm Audrey Hamilton, and this is speaking of psychology. Perry Halquitos is a professor of psychology and global health at New York University. For decades, his work has focused on the intersection of mental health and behavior with HIV
自美国艾滋病疫情高峰期开始以来，已经过去了30多年。那场疫情的幸存者如今已步入中年，仍在学习如何应对。与此同时，更有效的治疗方法改变了公众对这种疾病的看法。心理学家兼公共卫生专家佩里·哈尔基图斯（Perry Halkitis）在本期节目中谈到，心理科学在理解如何预防艾滋病以及如何帮助各类慢性病患者方面显得尤为重要。我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿（Audrey Hamilton），这是《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology）。佩里·哈尔基图斯是纽约大学心理学和全球健康教授。几十年来，他的工作一直专注于心理健康、行为与艾滋病之间的交叉领域。
prevention and treatment. His latest book, The AIDS Generation, Stories of Survival and Resilience, focuses on 15 gay men who survive the height of the AIDS epidemic and are continuing to live with the disease today. Dr. Halcidas, welcome. Thank you for having me. Your book talks a lot about the resilience of a generation that saw the worst of the AIDS epidemic. As a psychologist and someone who's living with HIV, it seems very important for you to talk about the mental and emotional impact this disease has had on survivors who are now in middle age. Can you tell us more about the people featured in your book
预防和治疗。他的最新著作《艾滋病一代：生存与韧性的故事》（The AIDS Generation: Stories of Survival and Resilience）聚焦于15位在艾滋病疫情高峰期幸存下来，并至今仍与该疾病共存的男同性恋者。哈尔基图斯博士，欢迎您。谢谢您的邀请。您的书谈到了很多关于那一代经历过艾滋病疫情最黑暗时期的人们的韧性。作为一名心理学家和艾滋病病毒感染者，对您来说，谈论这种疾病对如今已步入中年的幸存者所造成的心理和情感影响似乎非常重要。您能为我们详细介绍一下书中提到的这些人吗？
and their coping mechanisms? Are these mechanisms any different from those of people who suffer from other chronic health conditions? So the 15 stories that are represented in the book are 15 very different stories. I could have told 1,500 stories. There was no shortage of them out there. But I chose 15 men who came from different walks of life, from different parts of the country,
以及他们的应对机制吗？这些机制与那些患有其他慢性健康状况的人的应对机制有什么不同吗？书中呈现的15个故事是15个非常不同的故事。我本可以讲述1500个故事，因为这方面的素材并不短缺。但我选择了15位来自不同生活背景、不同地区的人，
different shape, sizes, colors, just to make sure that I capture the diversity of the experience of living with HIV for the last 30 years. It would be very easy to tell one story, right? But in fact, HIV is a complicated phenomenon, and people dealt with it in many different ways. So, for example, one of the men in the book became very sick when he was in his early 30s, and he is a composer and a piano player. And he thought all hope was lost.
有着不同的体型、肤色，只是为了确保我能捕捉到过去30年里艾滋病感染者经历的多样性。讲述一个故事很容易，对吧？但事实上，艾滋病是一个复杂的现象，人们以许多不同的方式应对它。例如，书中的一位男士在30出头时病得很重，他是一位作曲家和钢琴演奏家。他当时认为一切希望都破灭了。
And the way he was able to sort of come out of that was through his music. He used his music as a coping mechanism. he talks about how as he was starting to feel better and he would sit at the piano, the music would fill his body again. So the emotional life that the music gave him, revitalized him at a time when there were no effective treatments to actually destroy this virus. And I think that that's a very good example of the role that emotional life and social life plays in fighting this disease.
而他能够走出困境的方式是通过他的音乐。他把音乐作为一种应对机制。他谈到，当他开始感觉好转并坐在钢琴前时，音乐再次充盈了他的身体。因此，音乐赋予他的情感生活在没有有效药物来真正消灭这种病毒的时候，让他重获新生。我认为这是一个很好的例子，说明了情感生活和社会生活在抗击这种疾病中所起的作用。
For a very long time up to 1996, psychologists and social workers, and other clinicians were the support system for living with HIV. In 1996, everything changed with the advent of medications, but for a long time, people needed to attend through their emotional and social well-being. Other men turned to activism. One of the characters in the book, Jackson, I call him, became a very, very prominent figure enact up.
在1996年之前的很长一段时间里，心理学家、社会工作者和其他临床医生是艾滋病患者的支持系统。1996年，随着药物的出现，一切都改变了，但在很长一段时间里，人们需要关注他们的情感和社会福祉。其他人则转向了行动主义。书中的角色之一，我称他为杰克逊，成为了“艾滋病联合抵制力量”（ACT UP）中非常非常重要的人物。
And, you know, people think about Act Up as an important institution that fought for the development of medications and certainly they did. In the book, I take a slightly different approach in looking at this organization. And for me, what this organization did was that it provided a place for individuals who are living with HIV to come together
你知道，人们认为ACT UP是一个为争取药物研发而奋斗的重要机构，他们确实做到了。在书中，我对这个组织采取了略有不同的观察角度。对我而言，这个组织所做的是为艾滋病感染者提供了一个聚集在一起的地方，
and support each other and understand each other and created a social network and social cohesion. And we know very clearly from the health psychology literature that that kind of support system leads to better health outcomes. So that's two examples. The approaches that these men use, use to dealing with their disease inform how many people deal with their disease if they're doing it in an active and a proactive way, which is attending to their physical well-being, their social
互相支持、互相理解，并创造了社交网络和社会凝聚力。我们从健康心理学文献中非常清楚地知道，这种支持系统能带来更好的健康结果。所以这是两个例子。这些男士用来应对疾病的方法，为许多以积极和主动方式应对疾病的人提供了参考，即关注他们的身体健康、社会
well-being, and to their emotional well-being. So the lessons that we can take away from the men of the age generation not only inform the lives of those who are newly infected with HIV, but also individuals who are living with any challenging disease in our society. Now that people are living longer with HIV thanks to effective antiretroviral treatment. What kind of psychological help do they need to cope? Are there psychological concerns related to people with HIV knowing that they will have to take a battery of drugs for the rest of their lives? So the first thing that I would say in response to that question is that HIV is not just a medical condition. It is a bioseco-social one. It is an epidemic that is driven by a virus, but also by emotional and social factors.
福祉以及情感福祉。因此，我们可以从“艾滋病一代”的男士们身上汲取的经验，不仅能为新感染艾滋病的人提供参考，也能为我们社会中任何患有挑战性疾病的人提供参考。现在，由于有效的抗逆转录病毒治疗，艾滋病患者的寿命延长了。他们需要什么样的心理帮助来应对？对于艾滋病患者来说，知道自己余生必须服用大量药物，这是否会产生相关的心理问题？所以，针对这个问题，我首先要说的是，艾滋病不仅仅是一种医疗状况。它是一种生物-心理-社会状况。这是一场由病毒驱动的疫情，但也受到情感和社会因素的驱动。
and we can talk about that more fully. But with regard to your questions specifically, taking a battery of medications is a toll order. It's no easy task. Remembering every day that your HIV-positive when you swallow your pills is burdensome in some ways. As well as individuals live with and accept the fact that they're HIV-positive, there's always that peace in their minds that they're living with this chronic disease.
我们可以更充分地讨论这一点。但就您的问题而言，服用大量药物是一项艰巨的任务。这绝非易事。每天在吞下药片时提醒自己是艾滋病病毒携带者，在某种程度上是一种负担。当人们与艾滋病病毒共存并接受自己是阳性的事实时，他们的内心深处总会有一个角落意识到自己正患有这种慢性疾病。
So psychologists and psychology, which for a very long time was, critical in the development of behavioral interventions to fight the spread of this disease is as important today. What we don't want to happen with this epidemic is to make it purely a biomedical one. We know that people, yes, they have to take their medications. Yes, they have to go to their doctors, but they also have a social life and an emotional life that we must attend to. And those individuals who will do best in taking their medications every single day, suppressing their virus, remaining healthy, will also be attending to their emotional lives. They will be getting support from friends and from clinicians and from family members that lift them up to enhance
因此，心理学家和心理学——长期以来在开发抗击这种疾病传播的行为干预措施方面至关重要——在今天依然同样重要。我们不希望这场疫情变得纯粹是生物医学上的问题。我们知道，人们确实需要服药，确实需要去看医生，但他们也有必须关注的社会生活和情感生活。那些在每天服药、抑制病毒、保持健康方面做得最好的人，也会关注他们的情感生活。他们会从朋友、临床医生和家人那里获得支持，这些支持能提升
their well-being. And so psychology still has as much in my mind to contribute to fighting this epidemic as it did 30 years ago. And I think as psychologists, we have been on the forefront and continue to be in the forefront of developing structures and systems and approaches and interventions that speak to the true elements of people's lives. Let's talk a little bit about prevention. You know, people know how HIV is transmitted, yet they still engage in these risky behaviors. How is psychological research and practice helping people change those behaviors? So let me start by saying that people just don't wake up one day and say, I'm going to be a risk taker. I'm going to be a drug user. I'm going to be a meth addict, right? And I think that that's
他们的福祉。因此，在我看来，心理学在抗击这场疫情方面依然像30年前一样大有可为。我认为作为心理学家，我们一直处于前沿，并将继续处于开发结构、系统、方法和干预措施的前沿，以解决人们生活中真正的问题。让我们谈谈预防。你知道，人们知道艾滋病是如何传播的，但他们仍然从事这些危险行为。心理学研究和实践是如何帮助人们改变这些行为的？首先我想说，人们不会某天醒来就说，我要去冒险，我要去吸毒，我要去吸食冰毒，对吧？我认为这是一种
an oversimplification and a dangerous oversimplification. So my work, for the last decade has been informed by a theory of syndemics. And that theory is very deeply rooted in psychology. And here's basically what the theory says. Health problems coexist. So where you see mental health problems, you see substance use problems. Where you see substance use problems, you see sexual risk-taking issues. You see other diseases.
过度简化，而且是一种危险的过度简化。因此，我过去十年的工作一直受到“共生病”（syndemics）理论的影响。该理论深深植根于心理学。该理论的基本观点是：健康问题是共存的。所以，你在哪里看到心理健康问题，就会在哪里看到药物滥用问题。你在哪里看到药物滥用问题，就会在哪里看到性风险行为问题。你还会看到其他疾病。
You see obesity. You see smoking. You see all of these things functioning together and in some ways fueling each other. That's one piece of the theory. that health conditions are overlapping. But the other piece of the theory is that these health conditions are driven by psychosocial burdens. So individuals who experience discrimination and marginalization because of their race, because of
你看到肥胖。你看到吸烟。你看到所有这些事物共同作用，并在某种程度上相互助长。这是该理论的一部分，即健康状况是重叠的。但该理论的另一部分是，这些健康状况是由社会心理负担驱动的。因此，那些因种族、
their gender, because of their gender identity, because of their sexual orientation, because of their economic status, those individuals are feeling marginalized and experiencing emotional burdens at a much higher rate than others. Those emotional burdens in some ways engender the risk that people engage in because the risk is a coping mechanism for the realities of people's lives. So psychology is still really critical in understanding why HIV continues to exist in our country. When you think about who's affected by the disease, primarily gayed by sexual men, primarily gained by sexual men of color, you know, African-American women, and these are segments, these individuals are members of segments of our population that are
性别、性别认同、性取向、经济地位而遭受歧视和边缘化的人，他们感到被边缘化并承受着比其他人高得多的情感负担。这些情感负担在某种程度上导致了人们从事的风险行为，因为这种风险是应对现实生活的一种机制。因此，心理学在理解为什么艾滋病在我国持续存在方面仍然至关重要。当你想到谁受这种疾病影响最大时，主要是男同性恋和双性恋男性，主要是少数族裔的男同性恋和双性恋男性，你知道，非裔美国女性，这些都是我们人口中的一部分，他们
continue to be marginalized. And until we establish an equal playing field where all people have, you know, are treated the same way, that have the same rights, that have access to affordable good health care, we're going to continue to see this epidemic lodging itself in those groups that are experiencing the most discrimination. Well, let's talk about the introduction of Truvada then. This is the drug that has been shown to reduce the risk of contracting HIV. What impact do you think it's having or will have on the arc of the HIV-AIDS epidemic,
继续被边缘化。除非我们建立一个公平的竞争环境，让所有人都能受到同样的对待，拥有同样的权利，能够获得负担得起的优质医疗服务，否则我们将继续看到这种疫情在那些遭受最多歧视的群体中扎根。那么，让我们谈谈特鲁瓦达（Truvada）的引入。这种药物已被证明可以降低感染艾滋病的风险。你认为它对艾滋病疫情的发展轨迹有什么影响，或者将会有什么影响，
particularly among young people, some of these groups that you're talking about, who have grown up being constantly warned about the dangers of unprotected sex? So Truvada, as we know, is one of the HIV medications that is used for people who are living with the virus, which has been shown in trials to be effective in preventing the onset of the virus. of HIV. So if you take one Truvada once a day and engage in risk behaviors and are exposed to HIV, it is highly likely that you will not become infected because of this drug. When the drug is used that way, it's called pre-exposure prophylaxis or prep. Okay. So that's great, right? Here's the problem. Well, let me stop there and step back and say, here's the plus. The plus is we have another
特别是在年轻人中，在您提到的那些群体中，他们从小就被不断警告无保护性行为的危险？所以，特鲁瓦达，正如我们所知，是用于艾滋病病毒感染者的药物之一，试验表明它在预防艾滋病病毒感染方面是有效的。因此，如果你每天服用一次特鲁瓦达，并且从事风险行为并接触到艾滋病病毒，由于这种药物的作用，你极有可能不会被感染。当药物以这种方式使用时，它被称为暴露前预防（PrEP）。好的。这很好，对吧？问题在于。好吧，让我停在这里退后一步说，这是积极的一面。积极的一面是我们有了另一个
tool tool in the arsenal to fight HIV. Great. We'll take prep. We'll come back. We'll come it with clinical approaches, we'll combine it with behavioral interventions, we'll continue to do the work that we're doing. So one more tool, good tool. But this goes back to the point I raised earlier, which is we cannot think about this disease as purely a biomedical one, right? So taking one pill once a day sounds like a great idea, but we know that HIV-positive people have trouble taking their medications every day. Why are we to believe that HIV-negative people who are not living with the virus are going to take their medications every day. So while PrEP provides a situation for us and an opportunity for us to fight the virus on another front, it has to be coupled with
抗击艾滋病的工具。太好了。我们将使用PrEP。我们会回过头来，将其与临床方法相结合，将其与行为干预相结合，我们将继续做我们正在做的工作。所以，多了一个好工具。但这回到了我之前提出的观点，即我们不能认为这种疾病纯粹是生物医学上的，对吧？所以每天吃一片药听起来是个好主意，但我们知道艾滋病病毒感染者在每天按时服药方面都有困难。我们为什么要相信那些没有感染病毒的艾滋病病毒阴性者会每天按时服药呢？因此，虽然PrEP为我们提供了一个在另一个战线上抗击病毒的情况和机会，但它必须与
effective behavioral approaches that support taking the medication and with messaging and education from our community, from our governments, from our religious leaders, that HIV is a disease that is very much part of our reality and should not be stigmatized. And so I hope that we can nest prep within a larger framework of HIV prevention and care that thinks about physical, emotional, and social well-being of individuals. And you mentioned this stigma surrounding people who are HIV-positive is still a very serious concern and a barrier to care. What should psychology do to help overcome this stigma? Is it possible? Yeah, it's amazing to me as a 51-year-old man now who saw the height of the epidemic and all of the pain and suffering of the 80s if the stigma still exists. And I was reminded of it recently when I saw the reaction to the Ebola epidemic and how people were terrified and being hospitalized for no reason.
有效的行为方法相结合，以支持服药，并结合来自我们社区、政府、宗教领袖的信息和教育，即艾滋病是一种非常现实的疾病，不应被污名化。因此，我希望我们能将PrEP置于一个更广泛的艾滋病预防和护理框架内，考虑到个人的身体、情感和社会福祉。您提到了围绕艾滋病病毒感染者的污名化仍然是一个非常严重的问题，也是护理的障碍。心理学应该做些什么来帮助克服这种污名化？这可能吗？是的，作为一个现在51岁、见证了疫情高峰期以及80年代所有痛苦和折磨的男人，这种污名化依然存在，这让我感到震惊。最近看到人们对埃博拉疫情的反应，以及人们如何感到恐惧并无缘无故地被隔离，这让我想起了这一点。
Entering the country became more difficult. This was just, it raised all those emotions for me around what the 80s looked like, you know, where people were completely panicked. So stigma around HIV is very much still there. Some people still think HIV as a disease of gay people and of drug users. And in fact, we know that it's not that. It affects every segment of our population. But because of its historic roots and because sometimes more narrow-minded individuals use it as an opportunity to further marginalize some groups, stigma still exists.
进入这个国家变得更加困难。这只是唤起了我关于80年代是什么样子的所有情绪，你知道，人们完全陷入了恐慌。所以围绕艾滋病的污名化依然非常严重。有些人仍然认为艾滋病是同性恋和吸毒者的疾病。事实上，我们知道并非如此。它影响着我们人口的每一个阶层。但由于其历史根源，以及有时思想狭隘的人利用它作为进一步边缘化某些群体的机会，污名化依然存在。
So psychology is critically important. in helping to undermine stigma that exists in our society. And we have to remember one more thing, that people who might experience stigma because of HIV might be experiencing stigmas for many other reasons, because they're gay, because they're black, because they're poor, because they're from a certain neighborhood. And so what psychology continues to need to do
因此，心理学在帮助消除我们社会中存在的污名化方面至关重要。我们还必须记住一件事，那些可能因艾滋病而遭受污名化的人，可能因为许多其他原因而遭受污名化，因为他们是同性恋，因为他们是黑人，因为他们贫穷，因为他们来自某个特定的社区。因此，心理学需要继续做的是
is to continue to message to people how it is that we expect to treat others, to message to those who are living with the burdens and with the stigma, that it is okay to be vocal and to express one's feelings and ideas when one is being marginalized, to continue to train psychologists for the future, to work in hospitals and in schools, to teach people about the damaging effects of discrimination and marginalization. And I think that only psychology can do that. I mean, psychology is really critical in helping us advance how we think about issues like marriage equality. You know, psychology was really critical, you know, in the 1960s when interracial marriage was a complex issue for some people.
继续向人们传达我们应该如何对待他人，向那些承受着负担和污名的人传达，在被边缘化时大声疾呼并表达自己的感受和想法是可以的，继续为未来培养心理学家，在医院和学校工作，教导人们歧视和边缘化的破坏性影响。我认为只有心理学能做到这一点。我的意思是，心理学在帮助我们推进对婚姻平权等问题的思考方面确实至关重要。你知道，心理学在20世纪60年代跨种族婚姻对某些人来说是一个复杂问题时，确实至关重要。
And so we take the lessons from psychology that we've learned over the last 100 plus years and apply them to HIV, which is provide supports to people who are living with the virus to empower them, work to educate a new generation, normalize HIV in our society so that the stigma eventually dissipates. Thank you, Dr. Halquitas, has been very much. a very interesting conversation. Appreciate you taking the time. Thank you for having me. You can check out how Kedas's work and his latest book on our website, speakingofpsychology.org. With the American Psychological Association, Speaking of Psychology, I'm Audrey Hamilton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
因此，我们汲取过去100多年来从心理学中学到的经验，并将其应用于艾滋病，即为病毒感染者提供支持以赋予他们力量，努力教育新一代，使艾滋病在我们的社会中正常化，从而最终消除污名化。谢谢您，哈尔基图斯博士，这是一次非常有趣的谈话。感谢您抽出时间。谢谢您的邀请。您可以在我们的网站speakingofpsychology.org上查看哈尔基图斯的工作和他的最新著作。我是美国心理学会《心理学谈话》节目的奥黛丽·汉密尔顿。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。